jump right. Welcome everybody to another Zoom call again. A bunch of questions that were submitted,
they're just a reminder, if you're listening to this, and you get submitted to questions
ahead of time, then pretty much rest assured that for the end, it's really in a decent amount
time prior to start a Zoom call. So we had a bunch to go over. And then you can chat in questions
like everybody else here is a veteran. I guess we do a few new people today. Welcome. We are,
we record these and they're up on the member site for you to view. So if you can ever get on
a Zoom call, you have access. Provider again to use your member site for anything new. We don't
hardly have a lot of the new things that have been happening except the 6.2 upgrade to the true
right. So we'll talk about that. Information on blood glucose is on the home page of the member
site. So if you're taking your blood glucose on a regular basis, you can download a chart to keep track
of that. After weeks, sir, longer on that chart, but it's all off and you're taking your measurement,
take a picture of it and send it to me at lambsandconnorsclinic.com so we can get a kid
your charge here at the office and if I see anything concerning, I won't let you know.
Remember also as a member, you have access to all the courses. So if you want to learn more
stuff and you can jump on those courses and I think the most appropriate besides the cancer
course would be the autoimmune course. That's the one that I've updated the most because that deals
with more co-morbidities for cancer patients and your family members. Remember also between Zoom calls
to look at the blog. You can search that blog button right there. You can search our website.
This is on our website. So go to our website and search the blog and for anything there's a thousand
different blog posts right around there that you may find something that may be of interest to you
and answer your question before you have to wait until the next week but stay calm.
Now what's been announced last week was about the version 6.2
program update that's through right. The vast majority of you are running 6.4.
If your program is running by done 6.0 continue to do that.
Everybody from about three weeks ago on is now running 6.2. So 6.2 is a little bit different. I do
think it's an improvement now. Jake at TrueRife has pulled out his hair, getting it to work correctly.
To begin with, the first week that they were running it, it was an absolute utter catastrophe.
We had nothing but problems. Everybody was having problems. They've really done a big up job
getting it all corrected. I do think if the whole program is in improvement, understand
there's no new programs in that. I take it back. There are a few new programs that are only in the
6.2. None that you really need to be concerned about. So not worthy to have you updated to 6.2.
If you do go and update it to 6.2. If you're a computer geek and you know how to do that and
you go to TrueRife's website and you update to 6.2 or you call TrueRife and have them update it
to 6.2 for you. Understand your programs that I created for you will be gone. Disappeared
into the abyss ever to be seen again. However, I have it. So you know, but in order for us to fix it,
it's not as easy as sending you a flash drive unless you are really, really savvy with the computer
because you'll have to send us. You'll have to send us your computer back to us and I'll have to
get it updated. Put your programs in because there's a little hairy little tweet difference
with the 6.2 versus the 6.1 or the 6.0. It goes into a different file. Explain that on the
site so you can see that and it doesn't pertain to hardly what even calls. For those that are
it just received their right recently, they're running 6.2. But I do think it's a little bit better system.
So I am excited about it. I will eventually update mine. And for most of you, I was able to create
a shortcut on the desktop for easy access to your program. So it's actually getting better. So
if you do ever do want to update 6.2 just to have the latest greatest. Let us know you can set it to
us and we'll upgrade it to 6.2. If you do it through TRIV, they will probably charge you for that
you software. And then you'll lose your program and then you'll have to set it to us getting them.
So they're set it to us to do it. That's it about that. So if you have further questions about that,
you can really give us a call. Okay, so let's get to the questions here.
I watched a video from the Cancer Center for Helied Irving, California called Helied with voltage
or Dr. Jerry Teddett was interviewed. The theme was that all cells have voltage or charge.
The minimum to maintain health is 25 microvolts. And 50 microvolts is needed to heal when cells get
down to 5 microvolts. The polarity can actually lift resulted in serious disease, including cancer.
Dr. Teddett has designed a bio modulator to correct polarity and a biobio charger to raise cell
voltage. Are you familiar with this treatment center and with these therapies? Are they worth
looking into the treatments? I have been receiving, do not seem to be having the effect of my prostate
cancer progression. And I am now looking at other technologies and clinics where I can ramp
things up to manage my condition and new ways. So Dr. Teddett's book is a great book,
Helied with voltage. I'm very familiar with it. I've been, I've talked to him in the past.
Actually was going to interview him on one of my podcasts a number of years ago and somehow the
timing didn't work when we didn't get back together. I think that was right, but COVID hit. I actually
have one of his bio modulators. And I do agree that there's no argument from a physiology and a
physics standpoint that all your cells have a cell charge. It's actually held in a cell membrane
and it can be measured. He uses his bio modulator to measure charge. There's some disagreement
whether that is an accurate measurement of cell charge B, but I think it's a beneficial measurement.
The way that is typically agreed upon by scientists to measure cell charge is
with a different measurement device. And if anybody on this call is ever been to our office when we
used to have patients in office, we used to measure them with by putting little electrodes on their
hands and on their feet and measuring the impedance. It's called the bio impedance test. And it gives
what's called a phase angle. And that is a clinically relevant test. There's a lot of research
on phase angle and that bio impedance across cell membranes to measure cell membrane help.
So his bio modulator is like a teeny-mitty PMF device. You don't feel any tingle.
Like I said, I have one. Personally, if someone ever said, and this question has been asked
over the years, should I get a bio modulator from Dr. Tenet? I don't understand. I love Dr.
Tenet. He's a great Christian man. I really do like him and all the work that he does.
But I personally would not buy a bio modulator for treatment. You can get much
greater treatment and improving cell membrane health by using PMF. So when he came up with the
bio modulator, PMF was just starting up and just coming out. They were very, very expensive devices.
They're still expensive devices. But doing bite-ed a clinic near you that does PMF
if purchasing a PMF is out of the budget because they're about $8,000. So they're pretty expensive
devices as well. But a PMF is a much better tool to increase cell charge and to increase health
than the bio modulator is. So if you can do that, now in truth, the right does more than the
bio modulator, it is increasing cell charge. But the right doesn't do as much as a PMF
in increasing cell charge. The PMF does nothing to kill cancer. So either one of the PMF
nor the bio modulator, they regard our kids are killing device. They're working just to work on cell
charge. So cell charge is a real thing that's measured again in a device called a bio-impedance
testing machine and it's testing for phase angle. Phase angle is measurable, device measurable,
objective meter to see the health of a person not specific to cancer, but specific to overall health
persons. Phase angle is dropping over time. Their health is decreasing over that same time period.
So there's other things that I would suggest if a person's taken up. Well, my markers are getting
worse. I've been doing the right. What else should I be doing? Well, my question would be, are you doing
all your supplements? Are you doing your nutrition? Are you dealing with the psychology and the
spiritual aspect of your healing? Yes, I'm doing all of that. What else could I do? Well,
there are other things, devices that you could do, other therapies that you could do. Are you doing
copy elements? One of the greatest things to help decrease sympathetic drive and increase parasympathetic
stimulation and your vagal nerve over your parasympathetics are what stimulate your immune function to be
able to kill cancer cells? Also, are you doing a castoral packs of your liver or you're working on
detoxification pathways? So there's a list of different things that you could go down and do without
jumping in to buy another piece of equipment. But there's also things that you could do in other
clinics near you too, possibly a vitamin C, high dose vitamin C IVs that we've discussed at depth
on these zoom calls. There's some making it so does that you could do that could help you detox. So
there's a lot of different things that a person could do. So feel free to schedule and tell them that
we can talk about options for you specifically. Things are not going to leave. The clinic store carries
a supplement called trace mineral drops by concerned trace. Are these drops okay to take regularly? Okay,
so understand some things in our store are not necessarily things that I would recommend. I am never
recommended to trace mineral drops to anybody. So I didn't recommend them to the person who asked this
question. So why? Well, I want to take a liquid mineral. Why can't I take this? Because all these
liquid minerals are key-lated in correct way. They are elemental minerals. So let me finish the
question. Are the drops okay to take regularly? If diagnosed with Hodgkin's in the pulmonary
or other cancers is the ingredient lithium okay? So lithium is typically okay in a mineral supplement.
My struggle with the liquid minerals is that they are all the liquid minerals that I have ever seen
are elemental minerals. The only reason why we carry them at our stores because we've had demand
from non-patients asking for them. So we carry them at our store that our supplier has them so
that we ended up putting them on our store. I don't recommend people taking these and I may actually
have recommend put on this. I may not have it on this listing, but on the other liquid mineral
listings. I put on the listing that says Dr. Cutts says Dr. Cutts doesn't recommend these minerals
and I put on what I recommend. I don't think we should be consuming elemental minerals
than our from the earth. Now the reason is that we're not supposed to eat dirt. We're supposed to
eat plants. That's what we get our minerals from our plants and animals. But when an animal,
okay let's say a cow is eating grass. The cow is eating the minerals from the grass in a
form that's different than the soil. The cow doesn't eat dirt. The cow is eating grass.
It is getting the mineral that's key-lated so the a plant takes the mineral out of the soil and
key-lates it in a double bond to an amino acid and then we eat a mineral that's key-lated in a
double bond into an amino acid. These trace minerals that are liquid minerals are earth minerals.
They're not key-lated correctly and they're not a good form of minerals. So long story short,
don't use the trace minerals. Use the clear multi-min that we have private
label. That's the best mineral out there. Is lithium okay for anybody? Yes, the name is okay.
But minerals are okay for lymphoma patients. Just fine. But make sure you get them
in the right form, which is the correctly key-lated form, which is the aloea minerals,
which is the clear multi-min. I've had a history of constipation even though regularly eating
organic vegetable means seeds and nuts. Taking a magnesium supplement is a common recommendation.
The clinic store often offers a large variety of choices. What would be your thoughts on taking
magnesium supplements and which store items would be appropriate for me? My preference is to avoid
tablets, pills, or labored items. Okay, so this is I think the same person that asked this question
hence their desire to take this liquid mineral. So I get it. You know, we want to take liquid things
that might be easier to take. But with the minerals, you don't really have a choice. And magnesium
is immidial and you really don't have a choice with that either. So it's going to be in a powdered
form. It's going to either be encapsulated or it's going to be in a powdered tub and you'd have to
put it in water. So if you don't, so if you're taking there's there's multiple magnesium
items on the store because there's different the way they make what is used as the amino acid that
is collated with the magnesium can help the magnesium function differently. Like magnesium
three-odate would be really good to help you relax your brain and fall asleep. That's why you would
take that magnesium citrate tends to be a little bit more difficult to absorb tends to stay
on the gut and draws water to it. So typically when a person is dealing with constipation, the first
thing you think of is magnesium citrate. However, I prefer magnesium malate because I think it works
almost as good for constipation. But magnesium malate can be called me to the brain and can help
you rest. So I think that's a good medium is the magnesium malate. Now our magna clear that we have
in a powder and in a capsule actually has three different kinds of magnesium because the way they're
collated is it can help different things and that can help with constipation. So usually our
magna clear either in a powder or in a capsule form and yes, you'll have to put it in a little
smoothie or drink or something if you can't take swallow the capsule. You can certainly open up the
capsule if you don't want to buy the powder but that would the magna clear would be the best one I think.
I recently read across a product named Salisidium. So Salisidium is a glyco-benza aldehyde. So
aldehyde is a classification of organic compounds. And glyco-benza aldehyde is a type of aldehyde that
can help block the glycolysis pathway. So that's where Salisidium ranks. Now Salisidium I have read
about it years ago. There's an article about it in the tonsin newsletter. That's an alternative
newsletter that has a lot of cancer information in it that I read about a number of years ago.
I don't carry it. It's an expensive product and I just have not carried it at our store and I have
it tested for it. I did have a bottle years ago when it first came out and I used to test for it.
It didn't test very well. It ended up expiring it. I got rid of it and I just we'd ever ended up
carrying it. I never wrote about it in the book because I'd never really got into using it.
But I don't think there's anything wrong with trying something like that. So it has become more
available at that time when I was looking at the only place you could get it was New Zealand.
Or Australia. It was Australia, New Zealand. I couldn't remember where we could get it.
But it was difficult to get. I think it's maybe easier to obtain that.
But I don't know a whole lot more about it. But I know it works on the glycolysis pathway.
When we visited, I told you I had sore axillary node in my right arm. It is swollen. I'm losing
strength in any ideas. I'm also trying to do the easy peasy coffee. None of us three to four times
a day, but I'm having a hard time holding it. Does it do any good if you can't hold it?
So I'll grasp that first. So you're going to hold it for 30 seconds and you have to go and let it out.
Yes, you're still stimulating the vagal nerve. So absolutely continue to do it. I mean,
if you're just putting it in, it's just you can't hold it at all and it's just running out. Even at that,
you're still stimulating the vagal nerve. So I would say, you know, as long as it's too uncomfortable,
I would keep it up. As far as the axillary lymph node, if you're losing strength,
it must be putting pressure on one of the nerves. So I would, you know, I know you said,
I think you said you were using ice on it. I would try to, you, I would try a couple of different
techniques. So if you use ice on something to decrease swelling, if you have swelling around the node,
then typically that is what's recommended from a physical therapy standpoint.
However, some people react differently to ice and it doesn't work well for them. So
if you try alternating hot and cold, like do two minutes of ice and then take it off and put a hot pack
on there for two minutes and alternate back and forth, you might be able to get a puppy action. That's
the idea of that. And you could help get moved that out of there. I would also try some just motion
exercises to get flowage and contraction of muscles to get movement of fluid through there.
And just getting some motion in there might be able to get some fluid out of there so that it will
take some pressure off the nerve. Because if you're getting weakness in that orbit, I would think that
has to do with nerve pressure. So anything you can do to try to decrease inflammation of that area,
I think would be best. My diet recommendations for you say no to bone broth but
may I have regular broth homemade or stock store bought. The reason why we say no to bone broth is
because so understand bone broth is typically made by steeping bones, chicken bones or beef bones
for a long period of time. And the whole idea is you're drawing the nutrients out of the bone.
So bone broth is really big in what's called the gaps diet. And it was very popular, but a number of
years became very popular a number of years ago. It still is fairly popular to help heal the gut using
bone broth. So a lot of people were into making their own bone broth. They're cooking a chicken,
taking all the meat off of it and cooking the bones for a couple days to make a broth out of that.
And then filtering it out and just drinking the broth to help heal the gut. Why does that help heal
the gut? Because it has a very high concentration of glutamate in it. And glutamate,
El glutamate, the amino acid, really helps with growth. So when you drink a high concentration
of glutamate in bone broth or you take a gut healing supplement that has three, four or five grams
of glutamate, you can really help heal a damaged gut. And that can be very beneficial because
El glutamate really stimulates especially epithelial cell reproduction. And you'll reproduce
new cells helping heal the gut. Well, especially if you have an epithelial based cancer,
you're stimulating growth. So glutamate is a pathway of cancer cell growth. So you don't want
to do bone broth in general. Now there's nothing wrong with, I made soup, should I not make soup
because I make soup with the whole chicken and I boil it and then I take the meat off the bone.
Well, usually you take the bone out then and you put the meat back in the pot and you add your vegetables
and such and then you eat the soup. So you're not getting this super high concentration of glutamate.
If you're purposely making bone broths, the idea in the whole purpose of making bone broth
is to draw as much glutamate out of the bone as possible so that it's healing to your gut. So no,
whether you buy store-bought bone broth or you buy whole or you make homemade bone broth, it's really
a no to bone broth. But you can't have soup, just don't make bone broths.
Have you heard of Big Day Lane? It is a Chinese herb for cancer also is the oil. Okay,
there's many different Chinese herbs that I haven't gotten into for cancer and it partly has to do
with the purity and quality of those herbs and how to be able to obtain those. So there are some
of the Chinese herbs that are herbs that we use in our herbal different herbal products
but they're a different name. There's a lot of the Chinese herbs are herbs that are solely Chinese
herbs that are art herbs that are used in in really very many other countries and certainly not
in North America. So against trying any of the Chinese herbs, no absolutely not.
If you've been led to try one of those and we have a couple of patients, maybe you've been around
this call that are working with the Chinese doctor or acupuncturists that are getting Chinese herbs
from them as well. So I have no troubles doing that. Also is it the oil drops that you recommended from
5cb.com. Yes, that is that is the 5cb.com. That's what I said you could give it a try. The gummies
I had didn't work at all. Maybe wired most of the time. So let's talk about that. So if a person
is doing gummies, this person is talking about using THC to help with pain and to help with sleep.
If so in general CBD and THC can be beneficial to decrease anxiety, decrease pain,
increase relaxation and help with sleep. Now understand the difference between CBD and THC. So
THC is the psychoactive component of hemp or marijuana. THC is typically from marijuana. CBD
just about any CBD on the market today is from hemp, not from marijuana. So hemp and marijuana are
in the same family, but they are not the same plant. So hemp does have a little bit of THC in it,
but nothing that would change your psyche in any way. THC from marijuana is psychoactive and it has
other benefits. So there's a benefit to both. If a person has high amounts of pain, but
if they might be on some medication for pain and they're trying to decrease that medication
and they ask, can I start taking high dose CBD to decrease the pain? The answer is
in my experience, no. Even if you take very, very, very high doses of CBD, it's really not going
to cut the pain if you're on a pain medication. If a person has very mild pain for muscle exertion
or something like that, and they take CBD, they might get some relaxation of the muscle and they
might have a decrease in the pain. But if you have pain from cancer, from a tastasis and you're
at a point of having to take medication for that pain, CBD is not going to work. Will THC
decrease pain in an instance like that? The answer is on many people, yes. But the form of that THC
is going to need to be experimented with. So the THC in different gummies
is going to be absorbed at different rates. So when you take THC with something sweet like a gummy,
you will absorb it very quickly. And you'll get a spike of THC in the bloodstream,
which a lot of people like typically gummies with THC are used recreationally for people.
So personally, if you were with me a few years ago, I think I shared on the Zoom call My Experience
with THC, which quite honestly was downright hilarious for everybody, but me. So I,
what I was super sick, I did the high dose THC in the form of rick Simpson oil, which was not a
gummy. It was, it's a paste and it's like a tar that's in a squirt tube, like a syringe, that you have
to syringe out, because it's literally like tar. And you have to squirt it out under your finger and
you have to bite it off your finger, basically, because it doesn't dissolve in your saliva. And you have
to suck the tar off of your finger. It's very, very high concentrated THC. And I actually took too much
and there's a hilarious story about that, but that's another story. So that form of THC in that high
concentration is used called, that's called rick Simpson's oil, and that is used to kill cancer.
But it has the high degree of side effects, making you so sticky, loopy, that you could regret
taking it. But there's been tons and tons and tons of stories of people that have, quote,
unquote, put themselves into remission using rick Simpson oil. So I'm not against using rick Simpson oil
by any stretch of imagination. We just can't legally sell it here, but we can talk about it.
So that's a choice. Now, that's using THC for the purpose of killing cancer. That's not using THC
for the purpose of pain. However, there's people that have been on rick Simpson before had success.
And maybe their cancer is kind of raising its ugly head again, and their pain is really bad. And
they'll use a little bit of the rick Simpson oil, which is the tar THC high concentration THC
to help with pain, and they get some relief for that. Now, different people have different tolerance
levels. I mean, I never trade drugs. I've never done recreational drugs. I've never smoked anything.
I'm like a complete novice in that. So my story taking too much of the rick Simpson oil because it's
sat in the car on a summer day, and I got home and it squirted way too much onto my figure, and I took it,
and I was completely loopy, and it was a funny story, was not a good experience. It made me
not want to try that again. If my cancer ever raises its ugly head again, would I ever try
the rick Simpson oil again? I would because there is it. There's no, I mean, besides it making you
feel weird in loopy, it can't really hurt you. Now, this person isn't even asking that question,
but I just wanted to address this. We haven't talked about this for a while using rick Simpson oil
and or THC. So this person is talking about using a much lower concentration of THC to help with
pain. So I gave this person this website 5cbd.com because this website sells low dose THC CBD
combinations of different combinations, and they have a license to do that, and you can buy it from
them in every state, I think. So you can order it online from them. They have, I think, up to 10
milligrams THC, and it's always in a combination. So if you do it in a gummy, you're going to get a spike,
because when THC is in a sugar, you're going to absorb it very quickly, and it's going to stay
in your system a short period of time. So you're going to get a spike of THC in your system,
and that's why people take it recreationally in a gummy. They feel all loopy and fun, and I guess
that's enjoyable to me. I was not enjoying it, but I guess that's really enjoyable to some people,
and it's great. But I have had people use the gummy to help them sleep. They just want a spike of THC
to calm their brain so they can fall asleep. However, people react differently to THC. Some people
that's going to make them, some people, two milligrams is going to be perfect to help them sleep. Some
people, five milligrams, some people, ten milligrams, some people can't do the gummies at all because they
can't tolerate the spike. If that's the case, then you should take it either in an oil, and this company
sells droppers in oil, so it's not sugar, and you'll get a slower curve of THC absorbing. It'll
stay in your system longer, but at a lower level, and then it'll drop off. So for this person who did
not tolerate it, if you tried THC in the past, and you didn't tolerate it, look at taking it in a
different form. I took gummies before. Well, gummies are going to be in a sugar form. It's going to be a
high spike in a drop. Well, then try it in a liquid form that's in a oil, or bake it in a baked
good, but typically that's going to be a sugar, or take it in what's called a butter, which isn't a fat.
So take it in a fat, or eat some fatty food like peanut butter, or something, and then use a liquid
dropper of that. So you're going to try different forms. You've got to experiment with it to see what
work, and you've got to experiment with what to see with the dosage, milligram dosage will be best for
you, because honestly, it's different for everybody. Everybody's system is different. Everybody's tolerance
to THC is different. You're going to have to try it, but if you tried gummies, and you didn't like gummies,
you probably won't like gummies from any other source, try a different liquid form, oil form,
take it in with the fats, something like that. Okay, the next question. I am wondering if
sauna is appropriate for someone diagnosed with blood Hodgkin's lymphoma. I've read different views.
If appropriate is there a particular brand to use. So with lymphoma,
a sauna, there's different views of this. So a sauna with lymphoma, because a sauna is
is going to, it can increase swelling, right? So that's the whole idea. You've got heat. So with any
heat, you can increase some swelling. If you have a lymphoma at a certain site, it can appear to get
bigger, and it can get irritated. That's not with everybody. We have people maybe even on this
call that have lymphoma that are used to sauna and felt fantastic afterwards. It gets done to
the point of why you're using a sauna. The purpose of using a sauna is to sweat, to get, to help you
detox, to take pressure off of your liver, in your kidneys, and that's the purpose of the sauna.
I think where people get, where people have a bad experience with a sauna, and it's not just lymphoma
patients, it is when they try it too quickly, too much, for too long. So with any sauna, you should try
it for a short period of time. Get in there for five minutes. You do five minutes until
we can tolerate that just fine. I did fine with that. I'm going to try to do seven minutes
the next time, the next day, I'm going to try to do eight minutes. You gradually move up with the
sauna. That's mine. That's what I would recommend. And you don't try to do too high of a heat. I
typically recommend just 140 degrees to the sauna. What brand to use? We have people on this call that
have, many of them have sunas and they all have different brands of sauna. Really, there are sunas that
are out there that are that are boast that they're the sparring for a sauna or they're this mixed
infrared sauna or they're a near infrared sauna. And this is why it's better blah, blah, blah.
The truth is all the infrareds on us really have very little infrared at all. So don't get caught up
on that aspect at all. The purpose of the sauna is not to get infrared because the truth,
none of the sodas have very much infrared. Literally a five inch by six inch infrared plate costs
about $4,000. So when you buy a sauna for $1,000 or $1,500. And it's because they're boasting about
type of infrared. There's literally almost no infrared coming out of that plate. That's just not true.
So don't hang out on that piece. The purpose of a sauna is not to get infrared. The purpose of
a sauna is to get heat. The purpose of a sauna is to heat up your body so you sweat. And the purpose
of that is to take pressure off your liver and your kidneys. So your detoxing through your skin.
So your skin is an organ of detoxification, but it's only an organ of detoxification
if you're using the sweat glands. So if you go outside in the summer and you're working in the
garden and you're sweating and you are working up a really good sweat, you don't need to take a sauna
today. So I have a sauna. I don't use it in the summer at all. So because I'm outside sweating.
So that being said, what kind of sauna should you get? Well personally, I like the
sauna where that zip up in your head is exposed. Because of my sinus conditions, I do not like to go
in a enclosed sauna where I'm in it. My head gets stuffy. My sinus is get stuffy. And I get
a little bit claustrophobic because of that. And I feel don't feel good in it. I want to get out
after five minutes. My sauna that I zip up on my head is exposed. I feel like I can breathe. I can
stay in that much longer. Again, when I start doing the sauna again, this winter, I will start
probably at five minutes. Maybe I'll tolerate 10 minutes right away. So they've been doing it
in over a year. And I'll use it like that, but I'll still only do a maximum of about 30 minutes.
I think that's what I recommend personally. I only do a maximum of about 20 minutes.
So those sodas, the nice thing about those zip up sodas is they're a lot cheaper to
and they heat up a lot faster. But if you have access to one of those, those wouldn't step together.
Sodas that are really, really popular and they sell at Costco and things like that. Somebody's
going to give you one of those dishes. That if you look on Craigslist, sometimes you can find a
use soda because people buy it with the greatest desires and they use it three times and it becomes
something that they hang their clothes out of there. Finally, their wife says, we got to get rid of it
done thing. So lots of times you could find them used for really cheap. So look at that. But you got
it. If you'd ever tried something, I would try it. You know, find something that has what a
try one first because you might hate it. And it's not just with lymphoma with some cancers.
Let's say I have metastas to an axillary lymph node. A soda might make it worse like the person who
asked the question before. It might make it feel worse. It kind of feels more swollen and they don't like
it. So you have to try it. And that's why a lot of things there are mixed views on it because the truth
is what works for one person doesn't work for another person. And I bet you if we open up the
phone line, they'd be a bunch of people and say, oh, I have this and I love my soda and other people's
android. I don't like soda. I just don't do it. So everybody's different. So you got to just give it a shot.
And as far as low EMF unit, I don't know. I tested our one that we have on our store. And for EMFs,
it is very low EMF. I don't know. I haven't tested the other ones on the market.
So we do sell the zip up one. And it's just drop ship from the manufacturer.
And if you do want it from us, you have to, we used to sell it for 10% off because I just want to
sell it at cost. But then the company that we buy it from called us, actually, this is about
six months ago or so, call us said, we keep it selling for cheaper. This is, you know, it's going
to get sold in people and sell it. So if you do buy it for us, call us and we'll give you a 10% off
of the soda. We just can't put it on the store at that place. This is a reminder. If you're
taking a ironed for low hemoglobin, low iron, ademia, make sure you're also taking
animcited with your iron. Take one of these with, at least one of these with each iron cap,
so that you're taking. Okay. Questions that we're sorry that you asked. Again, if you're new
to the zoom call, you could chat in a question. And that's what we're going to answer right now.
In my most recent cheek swab, you told me to begin eating 130 to 150 grams of protein a day.
This seems overwhelming. I don't know what that's, I don't know what that's, it's very overwhelming.
What are good ways of getting protein in your diet over the course of the day? I have been
all eating one four out of serving a meat a day for 18 months. So just all of the research that has been
coming out about grams of protein necessary to stimulate lymphocyte function. So in order, you
could have normal white blood cell count of a CBC. Normal lymphocyte count of a CBC. But we're talking
about lymphocyte function is completely dependent on protein levels. And the research coming out is
when you increase protein levels, you increase the activity of natural killer cells and
your T cells, which are so important, which are everything when it comes to killing cancer.
So we've really changed our tool in the last six months and written some blog posts about this,
about what has been shown to increase activity is when you eat
the liver of grams of protein equivalent to your weight. So if weight, you weigh 200 pounds,
you should eat 200 grams of protein a day. And that seems overwhelming. It's almost impossible
if you're a vegetarian. It's very, very difficult. So I just want you to strive to that and it's
you're going to have to take some working up to that and make sure if you haven't been eating a lot
of meat and you start eating some meat that you do incorporate some digestive enzymes with your meals
because you don't want to get constipated. So if your system has not been
accustomed to eating a lot of protein, you may need some digestive enzymes to help with the breakdown
of that protein so you absorb it better. So just work towards that. Don't think you're going to do
that right now. Unfortunately my cancer markers have just gone a bit. Okay, so maybe we
want to chat about anything we need to tweak with that. And oh, you have to be careful.
Commenting on medicine, but can you comment on what cancer patients seem to benefit from the
off-label drug that bed is on? Have you ever seen it help someone with a variant cancer?
We have a number of our members on the bed is all. And because it's an over-the-counter
medication, I have no trouble recommending it. And so when we test for it, so I can test positive
I tell people to take it. So we have dozens of bedrooms on it. But you know, granted you know
a variant cancer, we don't have dozens and dozens of very cancer patients. And I don't let's talk
my head recall that I had anybody on it with a variant cancer. That being said, I mean there's really
almost no, there's almost no, I say almost, no downside to taking advantage. So it's not a drug
that's hard on your liver, it's drug that's cut out for decades. The amount that you're taking
is you know, equivalent to what you take, which you'd give a 10 pound dog. So you're taking
really, it should be called low dose bedbed or something like that because you're taking a variant
low dose of the bedbed is on with the Joe Tipins. So I see no problem in any bedbed is on
to your pro to anybody's pro call. It's really going to hurt you. So I've had one person
over all the years that we've been using bedbed is all say that it caused a stomach ache
or a stomach upset. They felt nauseous with it. But I'm not actually sure that that was the
culprit. Any supplement could cause a stomach upset if you took it on an empty stomach. The capsule
itself would be probably the culprit of that. Some people have sensitivity to capsules.
So I don't see anybody, I don't see any harm at taking it. I can't remember off the top of my head.
I remember having somebody with a variant cancer take it. So I can't answer that, but I don't
think there's any harm in giving it a try. And certainly the more of each fighter of cancer.
That and I have a mechanism as well. I should say, oh, I have a mechanism that I have to be a little
bit more careful. Comment it on. I can comment on it on this like a zoo call like this, but
recommend it in your protocol. I have to be a little more careful with that because that is a prescription
medication. But I have her back to this. Another drug that's been out for decades and decades.
It is different than Venezuela. It works on a little bit different pathway. But we have a lot of
patients that are taking both bedbedes on and I have her back to it. And I don't know. You never know,
I'm like, okay, doing really good. The cancers, not knowing how do you know what it is?
Is it derived? Is it the carcubina? Is it bedbedes all? Is it, you know, the person is usually
doing a lot of things. So it's not a matter of figuring out what it is. It's probably the combination
of things that created the result that you want to have. And the same thing, if you're not doing well,
you need to tweak your protocol because you just might be a combination of some other little twist or
tweak. And that's how we've been by promise to all of you is that I'm willing to twist and tweak
and figure out and learn and grow and try different things as much as we can to help you. I cannot
guarantee the results that we want to have, but I guarantee that all that's ever stopped trying and
learning. Can I send results to you to info at color splitting.com? Yes, you can send it to info at
color splitting.com. Labs at Dr. Clinic at color splitting.com or Dr. Cutters at color splitting.com.
They're all aliases to Dr. Cutters at color splitting.com. They all go to the same. They all go to my
clinic email. So labs or info, same thing, send the labs to there. Is it okay to take
Avamar on the day of the keynote? Yes, you can, because Avamar is not a
antioxidant, so good question. Yes, you can take that.
One of my friends had Rick Simpson oil to treat his cancer. And he was supposed to do it every day,
and he just decided not to do it because he didn't like the THC, and he basically got too high
on suggested dose. I couldn't tolerate it. I bought some from him to apply to
basal cell cancer skin lesion, but it was so sticky, it stopped after I stopped it for a short while.
So thanks for sharing your experience. Yeah, that's the biggest reason why people stop the Rick Simpson
protocol is because, you know, it's very, very high dose that you're supposed to take you three
grades of rice three times a day. You're up to a gram a day. I think that's equivalent to the question
before that person was taking a gummy that was 10 milligrams. You know, a gram is pretty high
compared to 10 milligrams. Okay, so a gram is 1000 milligrams. That is an enormous amount. It's,
you know, I've had some patients, I don't think anybody out here is on Rick Simpson oil right now,
but maybe you have tried it in the past when we've had people with patients in the past that have
used Rick Simpson. So I'll successfully, but I'll tell you, for every one person that used it successfully,
five people have used it and quit. So it wasn't that it was unsuccessful. It's that they couldn't
tolerate it. And, I mean, literally, I, again, I took too much the first dose because it was to start with
just a half a grade of rice and work up. And I accidentally squirted out too much. And I probably had
three grades of rice at my first dose. And it was just like I had a detox for a week before I
try it again. And then I tried it again at a very low dose. Quite honestly, I just didn't like the way
it made me feel. And I told my staff, I said, forget it. I would rather die than have to go through that.
But it's not true. I would try it again. If that, if I had to, but it really knocked me for a
loop. But again, I'm very much in office when it comes to any drugs. And I was just not used to taking it.
I've talked to people and we've had patients that have used marijuana in the past recreationally.
And they tolerate it in just fine. So I do think that it has to do with different tolerance levels
that you may have worked up to to. I have my first chemo tomorrow. I'm fasting today by
tumor paid. It's more intense when I'm hungry. Is there anything I can take from paid that won't
mess up the effect of fasting for chemo? I be proven THC gummies other. Well, you can take a
medication or you can take THC that won't mess up your fasting. So if you can think of fasting as
not having food, so your cells are hungry. Okay. And you can think of it in a cartoon like that.
So if you take any food in, then you're breaking your fast and you're you're kind of feeding
yourself. So they're not going to be as hungry when you take the chemo. But if you're taking a
medication, then that's just not the case. Some people even say that you take your supplements
while you're fasting. I think you should just really try to make your cancer cells as
hungry as possible. So also I am under weight. So fasting makes me feel very weak. Is there anything
I can have that won't mess with the effects of fasting, a chemo, coconut oil, tea coffee, other.
Again, there's differences opinion with that. I'd say coconut oil maybe, but coconut oil is a fat
that's going to break down into a fuel source. So I'd say no one to coconut oil. Many people
fast will still drink tea without any without any dairy product or anything like that. It's a
straight tea or straight black coffee and technically you're not breaking a fast by drinking black coffee
or just tea herbal tea. So I'd say yeah, if that makes you feel better using some herbal tea or
some coffee without any cream or anything and even even even a no dairy creamer, you're probably
just fine. Dr. Cutters, healthy drops dot com head. Life has life was almost done.
Does your store carry this? I found out yesterday that I could take with Artemis in a phone call.
Sorry, I could have you heard of healthy drops dot that I don't know what healthy drops dot
that is and I don't know if you're talking about
again, THCVD or the what liposomal you're taking, a liposomal curcumin.
I'm not sure what you're asking. I really look up at healthy drops.
Got that. They're just different oils.
It's it just seems like they are different cold-dressed oils.
They look like they have anything in them. It's healthy drops dot that.
I'm not sure what you're asking. You can clarify that. I'm going to get
finished that with all the Artemisidium total cause that this company uses.
Can I have that healthy means healthy? I don't know what to say.
Oh, here we go. Healthy drops and healthy drop are two different lipsticks.
Okay, so I will look at that offline. I'll look at that tomorrow and we'll get back to
my plan. All right, let's take it up for our time for today and thank you all for being with.
Make sure you're not shy and asking questions on the member site and looking up on anything else
that you might find on a blog post if you have a question that's birdie.
All right, thanks everybody for being on today. I know that I prayed for all of you and
daily basis and I love all of you. So have a good night.